members of Congress from both parties
say fired FBI director James Comey
should testify under oath about an
explosive memo he wrote it says
President Trump asked omit to end the
investigation of former national
security adviser Michael Flynn CBS News
has confirmed the memo first reported by
the New York Times the White House
denies that the president push Comey to
block the Flynn investigation major
Garrett is at the White House major good
morning good morning the meeting between
former FBI director James Comey and the
president happened here at the White
House the day after President Trump
fired former national security adviser
Michael Flynn and after that meeting
Comey wrote a memo to himself in it it
said and I quote quoting a president
according to a commis memo I hope you
can see your way clear to letting this
go to letting Flynn go he is a good guy
sources say Comey was known to document
conversations he believed could be
called a question or might at some point
in the future be legally relevant the
White House denied the Comey memoranda
saying and I quote the president has
never asked mr. Comey or anyone else to
end any investigation including any
investigation involving general Flynn
the president's sense of frustration
with all the controversy surrounding his
White House may be at the highest point
of his presidency not just the Comey
firing but the backlash over sharing
intelligence with the Russians has led
this president to question everyone in
his inner circle in some cases harshly
that includes for the very first time
Jared Kushner top adviser and son-in-law
to the president he is we are told one
of the voices that endorse the Comey
firing and the president is enraged that
that action has set so many negative
consequences in motion Norah enraged you
say major indeed all right major thank
you so much